she's spitting the truth I think
conspiracy theorist is a term to
downplay anybody who finds truth I think
the pandemic was completely orchestrated
by the world leaders and then on top of
them whoever is pulling the strings and
at the top we have Satan there is a
theory that Taylor Swift is a clone
Anton LA and his daughter who is on
record talking about how they use music
to control people and she has an uncanny
resemblance to Taylor Swift what are the
odds the Illuminati owns Hollywood the
media the food industry controls the
government I believe so okay and they're
agents of Satan I believe so she thinks
the president is a clone yeah I don't
think that it probably is Joe Biden so
you're pretty suspicious of like food
and big Pharma absolutely and what's the
purpose the purpose is to make us sick
because when we are sick we generate
Revenue she is absolutely right check
out the comments so many people agree